(whimsical Latin jazz with whistling)
(popping)
- Back again! (laughing)
So last time I tried tiny cooking,
and I feel like I was pretty good at it!
- Looks like I'm gonna tiny bake a cake?
Bake a tiny cake.
Tiny bake a tiny cake.
- I love baking, but I've
never done a tiny one, so.
(light jazz music)
- There's no instructions at all,
I'm just supposed to make a cake?
Oh, boy.
First thing, let's grease the pan!
And I'm just gonna use my fingers,
because I don't see a nice brush.
So I'm just gonna grease the pan.
- I'm gonna pour the cake
mix in here. (tapping)
Who knows much cake mix that is?
- I'm gonna say it's two-thirds
stuff to one-third water.
We're gonna start with that.
- Next thing, next water.
- Uh, just a little.
Okay, that is way too
much, I already know.
This is gonna be an eggy cake. (laughing)
- I think it should be, like,
folding like making a ribbons?
- Okay, I'm gonna pour this
into my greased cake pan.
- We're gonna put the cake in.
We're gonna cover the cake.
We're gonna light the briquets.
(playful music)
- So I'm gonna, oh, geez.
That's smokin'.
- (laughing) Smells like
sugar is burning. (laughing)
- Oh, it's goin', it's definitely rising.
Maybe I overfilled it,
'cause it's like (laughing)
almost at the top of the pan.
- 'Cause this left side you can see
is already gettin' a little burned.
So I'm gonna try to put it in this corner,
away from that heat.
- Oh, no!
I don't really know how to salvage this.
(playful, light music)
- So I wanted to make chocolate cake.
And I wanted to make ganache,
so I just brought heavy cream with me.
- I don't know if I can make a design,
a tiny design with this strawberry.
I'm tryin' to think.
- Look at that.
(popping)
- Yeah, this is what you want.
Ganache should be shiny.
- I should have made the cake taller.
(thumping and pounding)
- Okay, oop! (laughing)
Okay, we lost a little!
- Oh, it's really loose.
(tinkling piano music)
- Put a little bit of frosting here.
Sorta act as a cake glue.
- [Alix] Maybe I can try
to fill in this little hole
we have here.
(wailing)
(tinkling piano music)
- It actually looks pretty okay.
Not the worst.
- Sprinkles, oh my gosh, so cute.
My tiny strawberry shortcake.
- Okay, but my hands always
shakes when I do this.
(tinkling piano music)
- It actually tastes
great, tastes like cake!
- I think the pink saved the cake.
- Mm, you should eat it!
- Wow.
- Yeah.
- I think I did pretty
good at tiny baking!
- I get the appeal.
Although, I don't know how people
make these videos on their own.
- Nailed it, again!
(gently tinkling piano music)
(logo whooshes)
(hinge squeaks)